ségolène royal est l'invitée du premier
preuves par 3 de l'entre-deux tours sur
public sénat bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous ce soir vous êtes fortement
engagé dans cette campagne et cinq ans
après la précédente mais comme candidate
on s'en souvient vos conseils donc pour
aborder le débat télévisé face à nicolas
sarkozy ce seront certainement utile à
françois hollande christine pouget de l'
agence france-presse vous interrogera
notamment sur cette question dans un
instant et puis ce sera le tour de
perrine tarneaud de public sénat et les
téléspectateurs peuvent réagir en direct
à cette émission ségolène royal ils
peuvent même vous poser des questions
grâce à l'application tibi tchèque de
notre partenaire coran ainsi pâti voilà
c'est une émission participative
interactive via on va d'abord parlé
ensemble de la chasse aux électeurs de
marine le pen et de françois bayrou on
les oublie pas cela non plus hein
nicolas sarkozy a déclaré que la
présidente du front national est
compatible avec la république
est ce que vous êtes d'accord d'abord
avec cela d'abord si vous le permettez
le mot chasse ne me paraît pas tout à
fait opportun car notre préoccupation
est la préoccupation du candidat
socialiste de françois hollande c'est de
répondre aux problèmes des gens donc les
gens donc les gens se sont exprimés au
cours de ce premier tour et comme dans
toute démocratie il est légitime de
regarder les votes et de répondre en
rassemblant le plus grand nombre
possible de français en séduisant donc
les électeurs du premier tour en libye
fin nationale et de maintenant les
combats corps bien sûr alors en leur
disant que au fond s'il faut choisir
entre la peur et l'espoir il faut
choisir l'espoir accord alors vous allez
nous dire quelles sont vos solutions
mais sur le le jugement qui a été
apportée par le président candidat sur
la présidente qui la trouve donc c'est
vrai qu'elle était présidente à
l'élection qui la trouvent compatible
avec la république ou derrière la même
chose non je ne dirais pas la même chose
parce que je crois qu'il faut rester
extrêmement fermes et claires sur les
valeurs républicaines
en revanche je considère qu'elle n'est
pas propriétaire des voix qui se sont
portées sur l pourquoi parce que dans
ces électeurs qui se sont portés sur
elle
il y à des électeurs qui ont été
cruellement trahi par nicolas sarkozy
notamment lorsqu'il a parlé de la valeur
travail qu'il a fait tout le contraire
puisque ce sont finalement cinq années
au profit du capital qui se sont
développées les permissions de lecteurs
mais aussi venu de la gauche alors
j'allais venir il ya une partie des
électeurs qui sont venues de la gauche
parce que ce sont des électeurs qui ont
le sentiment de dévisser c'est à dire
qu'ils subissent la crise économique de
plein fouet la précarité les insécurités
de toutes sortes et ceux là ont exprimé
leur désarroi leur détresse et c'est
cela que nous devons entendre
aujourd'hui selon vous comment la gauche
pourrait leur manifester plus de
considération sachant que nicolas
sarkozy annonce est bien des mesures
spécifiques pour eux il est trop tard
pour annoncer des mesures spécifiques
comme ça dans une à trois jours d'une
élection ses électeurs en détresse nous
en avons tenu compte nous les avons
écoutés
donc il nous appartient maintenant
de montrer en quoi le projet de françois
hollande répond à ces préoccupations
par exemple sur la sécurité concernant
la peur devant la hausse des prix il y
aura le blocage immédiat du prix de
l'essence pour qu'elles peu près pour
trois mois mais le temps de mettre à
plat la question de la console la
constitution démarche permettra ensuite
de baisser le prix de l'essence sur ceux
aussi qui en peur du lendemain
par rapport à l'éducation de leurs
enfants par rapport au chômage des
jeunes
on sait que c'est au coeur du projet de
françois hollande puisque nous allons
redonner à l'éducation les moyens de
fonctionner et lorsqu'on écoute beaucoup
de parents notamment de mères seules
beaucoup de femmes qui sont allées plus
plus nombreuses
vers le vote du front national parmi ces
femmes
beaucoup de femmes petit petit retraité
qui bascule aujourd'hui dans la misère
parce qu'avec la hausse du prix des prix
et du coût de la vie
la hausse du coût aussi d'accès à la
santé ces femmes qui ont des retraites
très faibles se retrouvent en train de
basculer dans la pauvreté et dans la
précarité
il ya d'autres raisons vous savez
ségolène royal à ce vote front national
notamment un ras-le-bol devant
l'immigration c'est invisible comme on
les appelle aujourd'hui estime-t-il
sont plus chez eux vous l'entendez
est-ce que c'est un dossier délicat pour
la gauche que l'immigration
d'abord là aussi c'est une promesse
trahie de la part de monsieur sarkozy
qui avait promis notamment quartier
populaire de maîtriser les flux
migratoires clandestins et de maîtriser
les questions d'insécurité dans les
quartiers rien n'a été fait en matière
de fermeté
non seulement la gauche et le crédit
mais la gauche est volontaire et la
gauche
allam a la volonté de réussir le droit à
la sécurité pour tous et la gauche a la
volonté de négocier avec les pays
d'origine la maîtrise de migrations de
la misère est ce que la gauche juste à
la volonté aussi de résoudre la question
des migrations de la misère en posant
sur la table les questions du
co-développement et de l'utilisation des
fonds donnés au développement des pays
les plus pauvres
donc nous avons des solutions aussi par
rapport mais bon c'est le problème ce
soir qu'il n'y aura pas de
régularisation massive
il n'y aura pas de retard de leur cas
mais ça me fixe pas de limites
il n'y a pas de règle il n'y aura pas de
régularisation massive
il y aura la protection des quartiers
qui subissent les migrations de la
misère et il y aura je le répète une
prévention des migrations de la lozère
par des accords avec les pays d'origine
et par un travail sur le couesnon vous
savez que nicolas sarkozy va agiter il a
commencé différents chiffon rouge
notamment celui des régularisations et
il ya également celui du droit de vote
des étrangers aux élections locales pour
vous ça n'est pas une priorité
françois hollande dit lui aujourd'hui
que ça faisait partie de ces 60
propositions et que donc ce droit de
vote sera bien accordés durant le
quinquennat est ce que ça vous chagrine
pas du tout puisqu'il a réaffirmé que ce
ne serait pas la première mesure qu'il
prend la première mais écoutez à écouter
la droite a écouté l'ump on avait
l'impression que finalement la seule
réforme qu'allait faire le candidat du
futur président de la république serait
immédiatement de donner le droit de vote
il avait un mot d'ordre le soir du 1er
tour vous avez vu sur les plateaux de
télévision c'était mon dieu vous a
et donner le droit de vote et
régulariser massivement et ça va
continuer c'est un épouvantail et vous
savez les électeurs du front national
étant sensible peut-être au style vous
venez de le dire c'est un épouvantail
eh bien on ne fait pas de la politique
sérieusement avec des épouvantails et il
était absolument crucial de stopper
cette espèce de matraquage médiatique de
l'ump ce que j'ai fait en disant que le
droit de vote aux étrangers je le répète
c'est dans un projet quand vous pour vos
personnellement c'est dans le projet de
notre candidat dans votre projet mais
bon personnellement moi personnellement
je pense qu'il faut que le contexte s'y
prête à d'accord et c'est pour cela
c'est pour ça que c'est dans le plancher
mais c'est conforme à ce que vient de
dire françois hollande il a dit j'ai là
d'ailleurs les priorités de sa première
année de mandat
ces priorités c'est une autre façon de
présider de gouverner c'est de redonner
du pouvoir d'achat aux français et
d'améliorer leur vie quotidienne et
c'est d'abord de cette façon là il faut
un certain contexte pour ça sera dans le
cours du quinquennat puisque ça fait
partie de ses priorités apaisé il
faudrait que ce soit accepté par la
société où il ya moins de chômage tous
moins de précarité une société apaisée
et un débat consensuel bon ça lui aurait
d'ailleurs quinquennal au bailleur les
objectifs atteints et d'ailleurs quand
on reprend les déclarations mêmes les
déclarations de nicolas sarkozy sur le
droit de vote des étrangers souvenez
vous il ya très peu de temps il a lui
même soutenu cette idée là il a évolué
sur le sujet il a évolué depuis révolue
et puis donc en quelques jours ci évoque
aujourd'hui un contexte où tu peux
simplement vous dire la même chose le
contexte mais parfois alors qu'il cesse
donc de caricaturer nos positions et de
dire que c'est le seul à seul réforme
que nous allons faire maintenant les
choses sont claires et nettes
alors pour séduire je vais pas parler de
chasse ni même de pêche aux électeurs
vivre nationale ségolène royal nicolas
sarkozy
mais en avant à nouveau la valeur
travail mais il parle du vrai travail
qui l'oppose à l'assistanat et j'ai
envie de dire vous aussi vous vous
opposez le système d'annoncé je me
souviens bien oui oui légitime que l'on
fasse la différence entre le vrai
travail et l'assistanat qui irrite on le
sait une bonne partie des couches
populaires mais qui peut donner sa voix
au front national
d'abord ce n'est pas la première fois
qu'il nous raconte cette histoire
puisque en 2007 déjà il nous avait
promis la défense de la valeur travail
le travailler plus pour gagner plus et
je crois que les français ne vont pas se
faire avoir une seconde fois car que
s'est-il passé pendant cinq ans il a été
non seulement le président fin du vrai
travail il a été le président du capital
et il a été le président du vrai chômage
puisque nous avons mille chômeurs de
plus par jour et donc la question de la
valeur travail
elle est au coeur du projet de notre
candidat est au coeur du pacte
présidentiel aujourd'hui puisqu'il
s'agit d'abord et avant tout de réformer
le système bancaire pour que le système
bancaire se met au service du
développement des petites et moyennes
entreprises
ce qui n'a pas été fait et pour que
lorsque les banques seront renflouées
par l'état que l'état rentre au capital
des banques donc la défense du travail
elle se fait en donnant aux entreprises
les moyens de se développer et de créer
des emplois je vous écoute je vous
interromps sur le front national vous
faites un réquisitoire contre nicolas
sarkozy ça veut dire que vous estimez
qu'il est en partie responsable de la
percée de marine le pen
bien sûr puisqu'il est responsable de la
montée d insécurité dans tous les
domaines que ce soit la sécurité
physique au quotidien et dans les
quartiers qu'un le nombre de gens qui
ont dit on va tour national parce que
sur le trottoir de notre immeuble dans
notre hall d'immeuble maintenant on fait
les trafics de drogue sans que les peaux
la police n'est aujourd'hui les moyens
2002 les moyens d'intervenir
2002 ça fait combien
existent ils étaient éliminés du premier
tour par le front national en a pas
nuance 2007 sa faute et en 2007
le front national a été contenue à 10%
voilà ça veut dire aussi qu'on assure
parler aussi en 2007 avec l'ordre juste
avec les questions de repères avec ans
la lutte pour la sécurité et que ses
préoccupations là ont été intégrés
ensuite par les socialistes et sont
intégrés aujourd'hui dans le projet de
françois hollande avec la question de la
sécurité que les socialistes vont
prendre à bras le corps parce que ce
sont les plus précaires les plus pauvres
qui sont les victimes les manières
victimes de la sécurité sur les
électeurs centristes
vous ne les voyez pas françois bayrou
pour qui
devrait-il appelé à voter selon toute
logique selon vous qu on attend ça
sa prise de responsabilité l'avez vous
avez je prendrai mes responsabilités
dans sa prise de la france à bille je
crois qu'il devrait déjà avoir pris sa
responsabilité donc je vivais ressort il
attend le bébé je pense qu'il ne dira
rien comme d'habitude
et donc là aussi il n'est pas
propriétaire de ses voix et moi je
voudrais dire aux centristes aux
centristes humanistes avec lesquels
d'ailleurs je dirige la région qui va
des syndicalistes jusqu'aux centristes
humanistes je voudrais leur dire à tous
ceux là qui l'ont vu pendant cinq ans
les valeurs financières est remise
devant les valeurs humaines et que ceux
qui veulent que l'on remette les choses
à l'endroit
les valeurs humaines d'abord la lutte
contre la dette
aussi la répartition équitable des
efforts à faire et bien tout cela
doivent rejoindre notre candidat est ce
que le modem doit rejoindre
éventuellement demain la majorité
présidentielle autour de françois
hollande c'est tout ce qu'ils valent
venir seront et bienveillance hollande a
dit qu'il ne pratiqueraient pas
l'ouverture
non mais il a dit aussi qu'il
n'empêcherait pas tous ceux qui veulent
nous rejoindre de nous rejoindre pour la
porter à porter leurs suffrages marie
laure souffre à la majorité d'un
gouvernement vous imaginez
l'instance est pas ce qu'est prêt c'est
pas le problème
ce jour elle venir est contré dans les
dynamiques commentaires sont les
bienvenus
et un grand débat autour du front
républicain à l'ump certains un membre
du camp majoritaire s'inquiète de la
droitisation de la campagne de nicolas
sarkozy
vous par exemple si aux législatives
vous deviez choisir entre un candidat
front national est un candidat ump que
faites vous mais nous l'avons fait nous
nous n'avons eu aucune hésitation un
souvenir ou l'élection de jacques chirac
dont un jour là dessus aucune hésitation
il ya en effet l'apport de la propre
porte parole de nicolas sarkozy elle
même a dit qu'elle préférerait un
candidat socialiste par rapport à cette
droitisation donc je pense qu'il ya une
espèce de sauve-qui-peut là de la part
de monsieur sarkozy il est allé trop
loin finalement dans la récupération des
thèses du front national
et aujourd'hui il a du mal à s'en sortir
et donc il va jusqu'au bout de cette
logique de façon un peu désespérée et
c'est une plongée de l' agence
france-presse
va nous rejoindre mais d'abord aurait
évoqué ce qui va se passer le 2 mai à la
télévision donc le débat la
confrontation des deux finalistes et
vous êtes passé par là en souvient face
à nicolas sarkozy qui n'avait pas été si
offensif en tout cas pas agressif a mais
il se définit aujourd'hui comme un
boxeur sur d'exploser son rival à leurs
souvenirs et le son pour 2012 d'un
exercice qui n'auraient pu ré
l'importance que l'on dit pour et
fluence et le vote
sandra cerqueira adversaires depuis 25
ans les deux hommes se sont retrouvés
quatre fois sur des plateaux télé
ils ne se sont jamais ménagé pour être
désagréable c'est du blabla on sent
niveau mais parce que c'est ce genre de
formulation
si ça vous gêne c'est toujours pareil
avec vous et gentil au début puis après
ça tourne mal un avant-goût de débat
présidentiel comme prémonitoire la
rencontre du 2 mai prochain s'annonce
prometteuse tant elle crée la polémique
le p s obstine à ne vouloir qu'un débat
alors que l'ump en réclame 3 déjà en
1981 valéry giscard d'estaing veut deux
face à face pour obliger françois
mitterrand à sortir du flou la stratégie
n'est pas nouvelle
est ce qu'il a
cette confrontation des projets de vie
des personnes ça fait des semaines que
pratiquent l'art deux filles c'est pas
trois débats le problème le point ces
cinq années qui viennent de se dérouler
et qui ont été un échec de la présidence
du candidat sortant
en 2007 ségolène royal a tenté de mettre
son adversaire sous pression pour le
pousser à la faute lui a joué la carte
de la sérénité
coûte que coûte lamentable pas du doigt
parce que franchement non je ne
calmeront les parages il en a maintenant
il ya des colères qui sont parfaitement
saine mais en 2012 le candidat ump n'est
plus le favori
d'après son entourage il ne se
contentera pas de jouer la carte de la
stature présidentielle
on le promet agressif prêt à exploser
son adversaire prêt à le prendre à la
gorge
a priori le rapport de force mais très
défavorable et on sent bien qu'il va
vouloir secouer son adversaire face à
lui
françois hollande devrait garder son
calme répondre aux questions sans trop
couper la parole linverse de 2007
le refus de plusieurs débats et
d'ailleurs stratégique les socialistes
espèrent contraindre nicolas sarkozy à
lâcher c'est cool
françois hollande est plutôt d'une
nature dans ce type d'interventions
médiatiques où il est en phase défensive
comme on dit dans un match de football
et où n'a qu'à attendre l'adversaire et
éventuellement le tacler le prendre en
contre nouveau refus aujourd'hui de
françois hollande
il ne veut pas d'un débat sur les radios
un refus de plus qui permet à l'ump de
l'accusé de fuir et à nicolas sarkozy de
se mettre en position de challenger
voilà ségolène royal christine projet
nous a rejoint christine bonsoir web
question 1
alors justement ce débat avec les radios
qu'est ce que vous en pensez à ce que
vous croyez que sur landon a dû accepter
ce débat sur les radios
avec le débat télévisé qu'est ce que
vous en pensez vous je pense que les
règles ont été fixées et qu'il n'y a
aucune raison là de s'agiter et de
modifier les règles en plus monsieur
sarkozy on l'entend depuis cinq ans donc
il ne peut pas prétendre n'avoir pas eu
droit à la parole
il ya ensuite de grandes émissions de
télévision cours desquelles les français
vont pouvoir comparer et les deux
candidats dans le même exercice
et puis le débat de l'entre-deux-tours
tel qu'il est traditionnellement acte
est installé dans la vème république
donc un ça suffit pour vous oui un débat
ça suffit il ya déjà eu tout le débat a
finalement de cette campagne
présidentielle débat par le meeting
interposés toutes les interventions
l'audiovisuel les français aiment dit
qu'elle n'avait eu trop donc vous voyez
je pense qu'il faut se concentrer sur ce
moment symbolique fort de l'entre-deux
tours et françois hollande a
parfaitement raison de refuser comme ça
le changement un changement capricieux
des règles du jeu alors vous aviez
débattu avec monsieur sarkozy en 2007
et quel adversaire et est il à ce moment
là qu'elle débatteurs était-il est-ce
qu'il a changé votre avis de stratégie
vis-à-vis de monsieur hollande
en tout cas il déclare lui même avoir
changé puisqu'il d'éclat en utilisant
des démos qui relève plus du vocabulaire
sportif oui honnêtement on est dans une
campagne présidentielle les français en
ont assez justement d'être explosé ils
ont déjà suffisamment était donc je
n'aurai que qu'une chose à peut-être à
lui recommandé c'est justement de garder
son calme
lorsqu'on a vu cet extrait ou dans les
faits je je je manifeste ma réprobation
assez vivement parce que déjà à ce
moment là dans ce débat de la
présidentielle
nous abordons la question des enfants
handicapés à l'école et déjà je vois que
nicolas sarkozy membres et ne dit pas la
vérité
et quand ils utilisent le mot de seine
colère on voit aujourd'hui dans quelle
situation sont les français moi j'avais
déjà vu je voyais déjà une forme
d'imposture dans ce qui était dit par
rapport à ce qui allait être fait et la
suite mora a donné
son est ce que vous trouvez que le temps
de la campagne est plus dur que il ya
cinq ans violent même on peut utiliser
le mot je ne sais pas elle cédait le ton
de la campagne s'est volontairement par
le fait de deux des porte-parole de
l'ump du présent la république lui même
le candidat sortant dégradé on le voit
dans la façon dont les propositions sont
schématiser son âme caricaturer on le
voit dans l' usage de ce type de
vocabulaire
on le voit dans la façon dont le notre
candidat est traitée parfois donc lui la
la la force de garder son calme et je
crois que c'est en perdant sa fille
c'est une secte dans une fort vous
auriez un conseil à lui donner pour ce
débat justement notre de tout c'est de
rester lui même dans le cadre de ce les
différents cas de cette série d'annoncés
de cette tranquillité parce que c'est ce
dont les français ont besoin après avoir
été beaucoup chahutée beaucoup agité
beaucoup d'angoissé
au cours de ces dernières années et donc
je pense que c'est de cela dont les
français sont en vie aujourd'hui c'est
d'une personnalité de calme qui n'est
pas agité qui dit la vérité et qui dit
vraiment ce qu'il va faire et c'est
l'option nicolas sarkozy l'attend et il
estime qu'il ya du flou donc des loups
sur la seconde de questions l'embauchent
des fonctionnaires ou bien les
dissonances à gauche et bien le débat
permettra de clarifier tout cela mais
nicolas sarkozy aura aussi à répondre de
son bilan il ne pourra pas faire comme
en 2007 où déjà il avait fait croire
qu'il était le perdreau de l'année et
qu'il n'avait pas à assumer des
responsabilités ministérielles que la
droite déjà au pouvoir depuis cinq ans
là ça lui sera difficile de ne pas
assumer ses responsabilités non
seulement depuis 5 ans mais aussi depuis
dix ans là on dit toujours que le
premier tour de la présidentielle
détermine peu le profil de premier
ministre et quelle serait pour vous se
profilent les premiers
écoutez d'abord il faut gagner la
présidentielle et retient on va gagner a
répété jour il pense aussi être candidat
on sait aussi que la dynamique est là et
qu'un débat de l'entre-deux tours vient
conforter cette dynamique déterminant
c'est un débat d'entre deux tours c'est
un moment symbolique fort mais en
général ils confortent les positions des
uns et des autres et donc on peut
envisager la franchise pour matignon
alors meilleur c'est assez amusant
observer c'est qu'en 2007
j'avais proposé deux débats à nicolas
sarkozy qu'il a refusé à ce moment là à
l'époque et aujourd'hui c'est lui qui en
demande d'abord de maintenant 3 donc
c'est intéressant de voir le le
retournement pour revenir au profil
quand même madame royal qu'elle serait
ce profil je dire maintenant que
mélenchon est assez bas je dirai ce que
le profil de madame aubry est un peu
moins adaptées peut-être il n'y a plus
de deux je veux dire il ya moins de
caution à donner à la gauche
quel serait-il mais vous savez là la
nomination d'un premier ministre c'est
un moment d'abord très important de la
vie de nos institutions et cela relève
vraiment exclusivement de la compétence
du président de la république vous
pouvez vous pouvez juger le contexte
politique effectivement le rapport des
forces
quel profil l'excellent premier mini je
suis certaine rassemble personnalités
rassembleuse ça c'est pas pour ça suffit
ce tracé les socialistes et fille de
françois bayrou qui a donc obtenu 1,9
13,2 des voix dimanche qu'elle devrait
la stratégie en fait de françois
hollande
vous aviez voulu le rencontrer dans
l'entre-deux tours en 2007 et était
beaucoup plus haut voilà la donne était
différente elle a veillé 18,5 je crois
il était très courtisé à ce moment là
qu'elle pourrait être quand même parce
qu'il a besoin malgré tout françois
hollande de ses voix centristes qu'elle
pourrait être sa stratégie la stratégie
c'est une stratégie de rassemblement de
tous ceux qui veulent le changement
or il est clair dans le contenu la
campagne de françois bayrou qui l'a
violemment attaqué le
le bilan est l'action et le style de
nicolas sarkozy qu'il a vivement rappelé
quels étaient les fondamentaux de la
république notamment la république
impartiale la république morale qu'il a
remis en avant la question de la dette
publique c'est aussi la priorité de
françois hollande donc les électeurs
centristes doivent se retrouver dans
notre projet et dans nos valeurs et je
le dis d'autant plus facilement que je
dirige la région donc avec les
centristes humanistes et vraiment les
centristes doivent se retrouver sur
cette volonté de changement qui va
remettre les hommes et les femmes au
coeur du projet politique et qui va
remettre les valeurs humaines en avant
des valeurs financières
et c'est pour cela que je la conviction
que tout ces hommes et ces femmes qui
sont ce qui se situe au centre de
l'échiquier politique ne se retrouve pas
non plus dans la surenchère lepéniste
aujourd'hui de monsieur sarkozy est ce
que vous estimez comme benoît hamon
qu'une grande partie des électeurs du
front national sont que c'est une femme
non je crois qu'on ne peut pas dire cela
on ne peut pas dire ça il suffit
d'ailleurs d'entendre d'entendre les
électeurs
et la principale préoccupation leur
principale motivation c'est vraiment le
sentiment de dévisser et de ne plus
avoir sa vie en main et de fait et de
considérer que c'est une oligarchie
financière aussi qui dirigent le monde
et qui dirige le pays et c'est une
demande et une soif au contraire de
politique et d'un état fort qui va
remettre des règles du jeu qui va
remettre de la justice qui va remettre
de l'efficacité qui va reprendre en main
notre vie collectifs et qui va permettre
à tout un chacun de reprendre sa vie en
main et ce n'est pas parce que certains
électeurs qui se sont tournés vers ce
vote contestataire subissent aujourd'hui
également des flux migratoires non
contrôlée
regardons les choses en face que ils
sont que c'est nos folles ou racistes
pas du tout on a le droit de dire c'est
d'évoquer de formuler un certain nombre
de problèmes sans être considéré comme
comme un raciste
ce n'est pas du tout ce qui correspond à
l'état d'esprit de ses hommes et de ces
femmes qui s'ouvre vous vous êtes
toujours défini comme la porte parole
des sans voix alors qu'est ce que vous
allez avoir comme roule justement dans
cet entre deux tours ou où justement il
faut aller à la recherche de cette
france invisible est ce que vous allez
avoir encore un rôle plus fort dans
cette campagne d'entre deux tours je
porte cette parole là ne serait ce qu en
m'adressant à vous et dans cet état sans
vous dans ses centres n'ont m'adressant
à vous et donc grâce à vous à ceux qui
nous écoutent c'est à dire c'est ce
travail de pédagogie ce message
politique de respect cette volonté de
donner de la visibilité aux invisibles
comme je les dis de porter la voix des
sans voix de cons montré que dans le
projet de notre candidat il ya la prise
en compte de ces préoccupations et que
ce que nous voulons c'est que
l'espérance l'emportent sur la peur et
pour cela de donner des réponses
concrètes à l' angoisse du lendemain que
vous allez vous déplacer vous allez
faire des mythiques vous allez allez
faire du porte-à-porte je dire qui a
prouvé son efficacité qu est ce que vous
allez faire juste il est très important
d'abord c'est d'utiliser tous les
espaces de
médiatique d'expression parce que là je
m'adresse à beaucoup de français en ce
que je vais faire au cours des jours qui
viennent et puis bien évidemment me
rendre dans certains quartiers faire un
certain nombre de réunions publiques
là où ça pourra être utile dernière
question vous avez été candidate en 2007
mais pourquoi on vous a pas vu davantage
avec le candidat de 2012 à vincennes
notamment il beaucoup de gens se sont
étonnés que vous montiez pas sur la
tribune et que vous ne parliez pas à ces
gens qui vous attendait pourquoi écoutez
je crois que le parce que je ne suis pas
la candidate
voilà même donc pas ce qu'on vous a vu
très brièvement avec françois hollande
et tout le monde nous attendait à rennes
et vous étiez présente à vincennes dans
le enfin je veux dire là vous étiez là
mais vous ne vous êtes pas exprimé jeudi
ce qui est très important c'est le lien
qui est noué entre le candidat et et le
peuple
donc cette étape entre ce qui est
important oui c'est que ce lien ce nous
et que nous nous soyons autour de lui
dans le rassemblement
merci christine vous avez dit à
l'instant ségolène royal que vous étiez
persuadé de la victoire mais il peut y
avoir une surprise c'est ce que dit
n'est que la somme c'est bien sûr celle
en premier tour il peut y en avoir non
une hausse au second une remontée du
président-candidat vu les nouveaux
arguments là qu'ils avancent aujourd'hui
l'agitation qui est la sienne je ne
crois je ne crois pas que les français
vont vont adhérer à ces à ses stratégies
de de peur et de stress
très bien alors vous vous êtes imposé
dans cette campagne même sens vous
afficher directement aussi souvent que
certains militants le souhaitait donc
aux côtés du candidat
ségolène royal alors qu'au début il faut
dire que la tentation de vous zappez
vous et votre souvenir de 2007 a saisi
l'entourage de françois hollande mais
votre persévérance vous aurait conduit
d'après vos propres propos reproduits
dans le nouvel observateur vous
qualifiez vous même de femme la plus
importante de faire intervenir l'arrivée
juste après ce record
en fait dit elle souhaitait pouvoir les
confirmer les hackers mais tout cela
après le reportage de thèmes tran huy
qui fait courir ainsi les journalistes
pour qui cette forêt de caméras et de
micros
cinq ans après ségolène royal c'est
encore la star de solférino elle attire
toujours autant les journalistes les
télés les militants mais nouveauté pour
elle s'est aussi s'effacer et oui cette
année les lumières se porte avant tout
sur françois hollande
peut-être n'at-il pas été facile de
laisser la place mais il faut le
reconnaître la candidate socialiste de
2007 et fair play est en première ligne
dans cette campagne
pourtant après les primaires socialistes
ce n'était pas gagné
j'ai l'impression que à certain nombre
de gens pas forcément françois hollande
avait tendance à oublier un petit peu ce
qui était dû à ségolène royal et malgré
son échec terrible à la primaire et
dresse extrêmement populaire et je crois
qu'elle est populaire parce que les
socialistes les gens de gauche ont vu
qu'elle était totalement loyal
ségolène royal a aujourd'hui conquis sa
place dans la campagne
plus encore elle se considère comme
l'inspiratrice sur le fond comme sur la
forme
l'ordre juste c'est elle la sécurité
plus un tabou à gauche toujours elle
l'attention portée aux quartiers encore
elle s'est aussi l'initiatrice des
meeting en plein air elle a initié cela
notamment avec le grand rassemblement de
charléty entre les deux tours de la
campagne de 2007 s'était repris par
arnaud montebourg dans la campagne des
primaires et c'est maintenant ce que
pratiquent depuis plusieurs semaines
françois hollande on forme un temps sont
pas non plus les meetings pioneer qui
ont fait les scores et oui même si la
famille socialiste et rassembler
l'héritage de ségolène royal est
diversement appréciée reste que celle
qu'on décrivait au ps comme imprévisible
et incontrôlable s'est transformé en
combattante pour la victoire commune
mais aussi pour elle même elle se
verrait bien président de l'assemblée
nationale alors ségolène royal au
perchoir et son palais bourbon certains
y voient déjà d'autres s'en irrite déjà
vous répondrez aux uns et aux autres
ségolène royal sur cette perspective
personnelle
bonsoir perrine tarneaud est ce que vous
avez eu la tentation un moment de vous
effacer totalement de cette campagne
présidentielle pas du tout pas du tout
non non l'amertume de la défaite par
exemple à la primaire depuis vous
découragez jamais vous n'avez jamais eu
cette pensée
oui ça aurait pu me décourager c'est
vrai parce que ce sont quand même des
épreuves des épreuves difficiles et en
temps quand j'étais zapper du film du
bourget j'ai encore un peu de vérité un
peu de respect les choses en ont été
rétablies et maintenant peu importe je
dis assez bon s'est rétabli c'est
l'essentiel
cela s'était passé du candidat je peux
vous le dis j'ai pas besoin d'être
boosté je suis utile dans cette campagne
j'apporte ce que je tout ce que je peux
apporter
et d'ailleurs si 2012 arrive si nous
gagne en 2012 ce que je pense c'est peut
être parce qu'il y ait aussi 2007 et qui
a eu ces étapes là peut-être aussi parce
qu'il ya eu 2002 donc cesser la
construction c'est la muleta pas répéter
les mêmes erreurs qu'en 2007 par la
volonté de ne pas répéter les mêmes
erreurs et il ya surtout des chemins
nouveaux et les voies ouvertes qui ont
été posées comme ça vient d'être dit
dans votre reportage et que d'ailleurs
françois hollande assume totalement et
reconnaît totalement dans ses
interventions et corrigé bas la désunion
des socialistes c'est effectivement
qu'elle semblait par ailleurs le
candidat et vous vous étiez un peu seul
exactement bon tout le monde le sait
n'est pas un tabou donc cette leçon a
été tirée et françois allaire et dit lui
même dans une de ses interventions
publiques nous avons tiré la leçon de la
division il l'a dit même à rennes donc
ça c'est qu'un marin qui très fort parce
que c'est c'est rassurant pour les gens
de savoir que les socialistes sont
rassemblés à leur service et au bout du
compte
moi je suis une combattante politique et
je crois profondément à ce que je dis
est donc même s'il ya des épreuves à
surmonter le fait d'avoir des
convictions fortes et le fait d'aider
vraiment les socialistes à gagner pour
que le pays connaît sa nouvelle
espérance c'est quelque chose qui est
très important pour moi
qui fait de la politique depuis très
longtemps et jamais je n'abandonne les
combats qui sont justes dans un
reportage paru hier soir dans le journal
le monde la journaliste florence aubenas
vous décrit comme celle qui veut
apparaître comme la plus généreuse des
jeunes des généreuses la femme qui est
ce qu'ils n'ont pas aidé est ce que vous
vous reconnaissez dans ce portrait oui
c'est un très très joli portrait
d'ailleurs qui est très juste
puisqu'elle a suivi elle a observé
oui je vous ai dit de mon temps mais si
tu es juste c'est juste c'est un
dépassement de soi c'est parce que je
considère que la cause que je défends
est plus grande que nous et que
l'important ce n'est pas les zombies ce
ne sont pas les ambitions individuelles
c'est le combat collectif qui va
permettre à celui d'entre nous qui a été
désignée de gagner en notre nom à tous
donc une fois qu'on a compris cela
finalement que celui qui peut l'emporter
à gauche malgré la nostalgie du temps où
c'était vous votre campagne
oui bien sûr mais là on est dans le dans
le feu de dans le feu de l'action on
n'oublie rien la vie est faite de
souvenirs aussi et de méditation et de
réflexion mais la callas le combat
politique avec ce que sa demande
d'exigence et d'engagement heureusement
nous permet d'avancer et de donner le
mais le meilleur d'eux
de soi même est ce que la victoire de
françois hollande le 6 mai vous mangerez
de la défaite de 2007
je ne suis pas dans la vengeance je
pense surtout que c'est un une page
historique nouvelle qui va s'ouvrir
qu'il arrivera lors qu'il y aura de la
joie mais aussi de la gravité parce que
la france est quand même dans une
situation très difficile et que les
réformes devront venir rapidement dans
un contexte financier extrêmement
extrêmement dur équipements lourds et
que la soif à la fois de rassemblement
et de justice nous permettra je le pense
vraiment de réussir ensuite quand on est
candidat à la présidentielle il ya
nécessairement une transfiguration qui
s'opèrent on fend l'armure enfants
l'armure comme disait lionel jospin
quelles transformations à opérer
françois hollande je ne veux pas moi me
livrer aux constats ou aux commentaires
comme ça sur le sur les personnalités
parce que c'est toujours un peu
réducteur je vais vous dire une chose
vous savez c'est complexe d'une identité
quand même changé également pas
tellement non dahir était conforme à ce
qu'il avait voulu c'est à dire d'être un
président normal il est resté dans son
authenticité dans son hall un habit en
d'aussi gravité je vois pas d'où ce doux
lanvian la gravité de ces nu-pieds tout
à l'heure par exemple non c'est un mythe
penser que c'est drôle c'est pas une
pièce de théâtre ou voyez la politique
ou une élection présidentielle monde
écarté par quelque chose de spécial ça
dépend
regardez monsieur sarkozy qu'il soit on
va au fouquet's et quand même des fautes
majeures et qui montre qu'il n'a pas
forcément compris dès le départ les
servitudes et la grandeur de la fonction
françois hollande n'a pas abandonné son
humour dans les médias à la tribune
est-ce qu'on pourrait lui faire le
reproche peut être de montrer une
certaine légèreté qui n'iraient pas avec
la présidence de la république demain
s'il est élu au contraire on peut dire
beaucoup du forez d'abord il faut rester
il faut rester soi même déjà il faut pas
être imposable de près d'être préservée
mais en par l'humour on peut dire
beaucoup de
deux choses avec finesse en politique
est justement les dires sans agressivité
et donc on peut faire passer beaucoup de
messages par le parlement quel humour
cinglant aussi donc ça arrivait de tirer
votre chapeau quand même un nicolas
sarkozy vol avait beaucoup critiqué
depuis le début de cette édition mais il
continue de mener sa campagne tambour
battant avec son volontarisme ou dit pas
quand robin il fait le job il le fait de
façon qui peut vous impressionner non
parce que sur le fond je pense qu'il
dérape il fait le job physiquement mais
ça c'est la moindre des choses il est
dans un combat c'est aussi quelque chose
de passionnant à conduire mais sur le
prix sur les arguments je trouve qu'il a
dit il a dégradé ce moment essentiel de
la rencontre d'une personnalité
politique avec le peuple français ça je
trouve que c'est regrettable
une question de notre partenaire orange
tivi tchèque j'ai beaucoup de beaucoup
d'appels voilà une question de neige de
grenoble je le rappelle donc c'est une
application sur votre téléphone
voilà donc neige de grenoble qui vous
demande qui dit il faut un
renouvellement de la classe politique
c'est impossible de voir aujourd'hui le
retour de tous ces éléphants est ce que
ségolène royal vous êtes d'accord pour
limiter les mandats
à 15 ans maximum de monde après d'abord
je suis contre le cumul des mandats
je suis d'ailleurs la seule politique à
mettre appliquer ce principe à moi même
puisque lorsque j'ai été élu président
de région je ne suis pas représenté aux
élections législatives la limitation du
cumul dans le temps dans le temps c'est
ça c'est ce que croit mandat ça existe
dans d'autres pays
donc c'est dans le cadre de la
moralisation de la vie politique et de
la réforme des institutions que nous
aurons en effet examiner ce type de ce
type d'action en tout cas les ministres
ne pourront pas ça françois hollande
lundi ne pourront pas cumuler avec un
exécutif local
donc ça déjà c'est très important le
salaire du président de la république
sera baissé de 30%
vous êtes toujours candidate à la
présidence de l'assemblée nationale je
vous le dirai le moment venu mais je
je n'ai jamais caché que c'était une
perspective qui qui m'intéressait cela
dit quel président d'exercer à la tête
de l'assemblée nationale ça s'est un peu
trop tôt gagnant des choses à fédération
du fln est nouvelle mais je reviendrai
ma vitre et à ce moment je vis très mal
c'est que la fonction que ça intéresse
le perchoir ça vous obligera à quitter
votre région alors on verra je me rendis
oublié de votre région
je le vet nippo crittin vous ne vous
répondant pas où je vous ai répondu
clairement vous êtes intéressés voilà et
je lui ai déjà dit et je le redis ça
serait hypocrite de dire le contraire
choirat assemblée nationale et la
présidence de la région espère qu'il y
aura une loi sur le non-cumul des
mandats et que tout le monde
du coup obéir à ce sera sur la même
toise en quelque sorte
perrine troisième mise en examen
aujourd'hui de ziad takieddine dans l'
affaire karachi cette fois pour
blanchiment de fonds la sphère devient
embarrassante vous trouvez que c'est
l'accumulation des affaires bien sûr
elle devient embarrassante pour le pour
le pouvoir pour ce puisque je crois
qu'il a cité un certain nombre de
responsables politiques de droite et
c'est en effet avec ses mauvaises moeurs
qu'il faudra rompre définitivement vous
avait choqué en déclarant vous n'a pas
été la seule ensuite d'autres vous ont
rejoint new montebourg notamment en
déclarant que nicolas sarkozy était
candidat à sa réélection pour préserver
son immunité présidentielle
vous le pensez et vous pouvez le répéter
écoutez en tout cas ce qui est clair
c'est que dans le projet de françois
hollande
nous reviendrons sur l'immunité du
président de la république vous le savez
pour tous les délits de
de droit commun voilà et on sait qu'il
ya beaucoup de d'investigation de la
justice qui sont proches de l'actuel
président de la république
que pensez vous de la proposition de
françois bayrou de soumettre à la
majorité qualifiée des parlementaires la
nomination du ministre de la justice
non ça ne paraît pas une très bonne idée
il ya la composition d'un gouvernement
qui doit se faire sous l'autorité du
premier ministre et du président de la
république et les choix doivent cette
judicieuse tient d'hommes et de femmes
honnêtes et compétents
dernière question avec tivi tchèque
orange quand aurons nous enfin une femme
présidente de la république demande
patrick est ce qu'il est mais voté en
un jour il y aura d'autres
ce qui s'est passé en plus je crois que
la france serait dans un autre état que
celui d'aujourd'hui
mais vous savez que ça va être dur quand
même à partir du 7 mai la situation
économique est ce qui s'est passé dans
cinq ans en effet ça s'est bien dégradée
oui mais encourage l'imagination très
bien ce sera utile et la chance aussi
ça compte aussi merci merci ségolène
royal d'avoir été avec nous ce soir pour
cette émission de preuve par trois
bonsoir à tous et à très vite
à